The jogan Experience I'm a member of the
deaf community and I don't I think every
deaf person would say that that I I like
belong but I also was the enemy I was
the hearing and and so you're then why
do they think of the hearing as the
enemy well that is a complicated
question and it's because um there has
been a lot of enforced oppression on the
deaf Community from the from the outside
the story of sign language is really
fascinating um 300 years ago there was
no sign Lang language there was no there
was there was only the kind of sign if
you were born 90% of deaf people are
born into a hearing family right that's
just the way genetics works like most of
the time you don't have deaf family
members and if you were born 350 years
ago into one of those families you just
didn't have language you weren't given
the gift of language which is the thing
I mean think about how much language
plays into your own life Joe like yeah
speaking and think everything you know
every thought process you have is is
mashed through the filter of language
and in that situation you'd be born into
a family and you had zero language you
would have like a gesturing system that
you'd created with your dad to be able
to say like pass the potatoes and that
was it you couldn't say how you feel you
couldn't say what you wanted to do you
couldn't even think about how you I mean
you could think I don't know I mean I
wasn't I've never experienced that but
language is the thing that unlocks
reason it's the thing that unlocks
culture and people were styed from that
but if you were born lucky enough to
have genetic deafness in your family so
that you and your sibling were both
users both deaf then the two of you
sitting together could create language a
language of two right you would back and
forth between two siblings create a a
family sign system that would enable the
both of you learning from one another to
create a language and enable you to
reason and think and talk about how you
feel even if it was just with one person
could communicate with the outside world
but at least you could communicate with
yourself and with one other person I
mean the difference between an isolated
deaf person and a pair of siblings is
the world it's it's it's Freedom it's
everything so one day a French PR priest
walks along along and sees two deaf
sisters signing back and forth to one
another and he goes That's language
prior to that deaf people weren't even
considered to be linguistic they weren't
even considered to be capable of reason
but he goes no I know what that is I'm
looking at language so he goes to these
sisters his name was the ab deepe and he
says teach me to sign somehow he tells
them like you know teach me these
gestures to them teach to sign they
teach him to sign and he his thing was
he wanted them to take the catechism
right that they he wanted them to be
able to go to heaven he realized ohea
people have are linguistically capable
but they can't get into heaven unless
they can take the catechism and confess
their faith and take communion right
which right makes sense if there is a
God that God wouldn't allow them into
heaven based on the fact that they
couldn't speak he's like what I my hands
are tied here but so you have to say it
so they teach him they teach him and he
teaches them back French and then he
starts to gather the deaf people from
around the world uh I'm sorry from
around France and he creates the first
school for the deaf he teaches them
French in sign in sign that's right whoa
cuz French cuz sign language and spoken
language are not the same a lot of
people think that right that like I
speak American Sign Language but people
think oh it's a translation of English
it's not it's his complete own language
right so oh I did not know that so much
so that what the way that he would fund
raise for this school is he would do
like a traveling like Road show where he
would take his his star pupils around
France and around Europe and they would
be at like an exhibition Hall and a
person in the audience would ask a
question he would say oh Joe do you have
a question for the deaf person and then
You' ask them some French question like
you know what is what degree of
suffering can be born by man or how many
creams is too many creams for a Brie or
whatever and he would take your question
sign it to his star pupils and they
would take a piece of chalk walk up to
the Blackboard and write the answer in
perfect French and it people lost their
[__] mind like they couldn't believe
it like people oh my God it like
unlocked this whole conception of the as
like uh they can think they can reason
oh they all they need is language to be
free right so all this whole network of
De schools for the death started to
spring up they would they sprung up in
all over Europe and they would copy the
the teaching methods of the the school
for the deaf and um and and a guy from
America came over right and he saw this
system and he basically took their star
pupil and one of the things was the deaf
would teach each other so you would
teach them sign and then they would
become educated and then they would
become a professor at this school and he
took like the star Professor laurant
clerk was his name um Thomas gadet was
the name of the American he came over
and he saw lauron Clerk and he said move
to America with me and let's go do the
let's go replicate this in America so
Thomas gadet says yes they get on a boat
they sail to America by the time they
landed Thomas gadet new rudimentary sign
and Laurent clerk who was like a [__]
genius knew uh basically had been taught
English and they set up the first school
for the deaf in America figured out
English on a boat he was a Genius Like A
Real Genius Like A like an actual like
lucky enough to have been you know these
circumstances in history where like the
perfect man at the perfect time like
they come here they set up this school
here and they start to create American
Sign Language and they they borrowed
from these different worlds right they
took French sign language as the base
Martha's Vineyard uh back then had this
weird genetic anomaly on the island of
mar Vineyard this is like before it was
just a place for Kennedy to [__] their
Mistresses this was like back when it
was a fishing town a fishing island
there was some weird genetic thing that
had happened where over the course of
hundreds of years one in 25 people on
Martha's Vineyard was deaf whoa and it
was this very bizarre uh kind of like
like almost the equality that deaf
people on Martha's Vineyard felt was
almost like the opposite of like what uh
affirmative action is attempting to do
right affirmative action wants to
correct a historic harm by uh by
changing the playing field this was an
equity of everybody was the same because
everybody on Martha's Vineyard knew uh
either was deaf knew a deaf person or
was related to a deaf person so
everybody hearing and non-hearing signed
on Martha's Vineyard it was a a sign
system called uh Martha's Vineyard sign
language they took some of that they
took the Plains Indian sign language p s
l it's called you know that like gesture
um uh you've seen it in like movies
where the the Native Americans will will
gesture to each other and you think they
present it as if it's like a war
language so they don't have to make
noise but what it actually was was all
the tribes in uh America spoke different
languages so they created this kind of
uh Esperanto of the tribes so that they
could trade they could do trade and that
was called Plains Indian sign language
and they took all that into like kind of
bullia Baye of a French sign language
base Martha's Vineyard Chaser and Plains
Indians sprinkled on top and they
created American Sign Language and then
100 years 200 years later my mother was
born deaf uh in in in Oakland California
and she went to the California school
for the deaf and she absorbed this
language my mother was 13 when she went
to the California School for the Deaf
she was in other uh an oral school
system this is my long-winded way of
telling you why deaf people have such a
problem with hearing
people that language that she learned
she was she was in an oral school system
so almost as soon as the sign language
system came out hearing people looked at
it and go we got to get rid of that the
one thing that unlocked their Freedom
the one thing that unlocked their minds
hearing people saw it and said we have
to take that away from them we have to
make them more like us by doing the sign
they're creating more wakanda they're
creating an insular sort of closed
circuit system of culture right and
they're and weirdly this was at a time
in American history where those closed
circuits of culture were really frowned
upon this we were frowning upon deaf
people signing to each other deaf people
signing to each other Italians having
their own newspapers Chinese immigrants
like every at that time in American
history the idea of creating like an
immigrant subculture was was really
frowned upon and Alexander granbell
whose parents were deaf like me had a
deaf wife he became the champion of what
was called the oral system um and the
oral system was let's not let's not
allow them to sign let's teach them to
speak let's make them like us let's make
them talk normally and function normally
let's make them like us but it it was a
crazy failure BEC and it makes sense why
right like they can't hear the sounds
they can't hear the sounds Oliver Sach
said teaching a deaf person uh without
sign is like teaching you Japanese from
inside of a soundproof booth by holding
up flash cards in Japanese and like
putting a symbol next to it it was like
kind of doomed to failure and then they
went through this this 200 years
reimposed Darkness there was there was a
trial where all the hearing Educators
decided the deaf people wouldn't sign
anymore they fired all the de Educators
and they pushed them out and they
created this oral system which really I
mean it worked for some people some
people but what it created was you had
to be exceptional in order to be average
in the deaf world you know you had to be
a genius uh in order to get that oral
system to work for you because your
natural mode of communication had been
kind of stamped out and then in about
the the 70s deaf people started to like
kind of rise up and say [__] that we're
signing this is who we are this is our
native language and when I was born in
79 that was this that was the world I
was born into and and and so from that
two sisters on a [__] Corner in in a
slum in Paris to that school to gadet to
a boat ride to the Martha's Vineyard to
the California school to for the deaf to
my mother's hands to my hands that was
the way that I acquired language was
through this crazy historical journey
and that to me is is the reason that
that when I was born into the deaf
Community there was there was so much
distrust of the hearing world because
they were like they stole from us the
one thing that gave us freedom that
makes sense wow I did not know any of
that stuff that's
incredible what how does
someone get to be a fake sign language
interpretator and be on stage with Obama
was it Obama oh it's been multiple
people but there's one there was one
recently that happened yeah but the
Obama one was bananas cuz this guy was
totally insane and he was standing in
front of Obama just making things up
I'll tell you how good he want to see
can I see it the Obama guy how bad the
Obama guy is well I think it's just
gibberish I think he's just the sign
language version of gibberish I my life
was going to appointments with my mother
and being tasked with the job of
interpreting for my mom's medical
appointments for my mom it was like a a
non-consensual internship program like I
I like her medical appointments and then
I started to get in trouble and then the
the the subject of the meeting would be
me
it would be like a disciplinary meeting
about me so you would have to explain
what your mom was having a problem with
with you or what the school system or
what the Oakland Police Department what
their problem with me was oh my God and
then you have to do this kind of like
this kind of interpretive dance where
you're you're not you can't be like oh
we think your son is awesome he's a cool
kid we love him cuz then your mom my
mom's not stupid she'll be like all
right let's see how bad this guy is Guy
okay well that's not Obama no that's not
the one this is the guy I remember there
oh this was in at the Nelson Mandela
Memorial yeah so check this dude out
this video doesn't have him net with
Obama okay just show him by himself with
that other gentleman so what what is he
doing here mosha I I am at a
disadvantage Joe because I this is South
Africa and I do not speak South African
sign language but I remember this guy a
a South African sign language I I would
assume every system you want to hear
something crazy it is so not a transl of
English that uh my mother know would
have a much harder time understanding a
British sign sign signer than a French
signer whoa so it has nothing it's
divorced from English wow right ah this
lady okay so I can tell you that this
woman is actually using sign language
this is actual sign language but she is
very bad at sign language is that what
it is yes those are real letters and I
this is completely incomprehensible 55
million is what she just said I don't
know what that is
please announcement tonight handcuffs
she look she waved her arms around like
she was singing Jingle Bells but that's
not true right if she's doing some sign
language well she's a hustler what
whatever this is but I did dude I've
been to so many appointments with my
mother with my mother where I walk in
and and and it's an emergency room
appointment and I go you can leave just
leave because you aren't qualified to do
this and this is [__] life or death
for my mother and you're here you
shouldn't have taken this [__] job
you should have known better than to
take this job because this is an
emergency room situation so that's when
I was an interpreter the the
responsibility of that was like massive
to me I I I I felt that so acutely
because I'd lived through it in such a
direct way right I've told I've been an
interpreter when people were told they
were dying I've been an interpreter when
people were were graduated from graduate
school from like getting their doctorate
all the I've been an interpreter where
people were court and it was literally
the the the degree to which I could sign
accurately and Faithfully was the
difference between them going to prison
and not going to prison like I've done
all of that and that that that weight is
like super massive to me and super
imagine yeah and some funny [__] has
happened along the way too I'm sure like
some very strange situations what how
does the deaf Community feel about
people who get like implants and can
hear again so that's a another
complicated question um I think have you
ever seen the sound in the fury no it's
a [__] beautiful and fantastic
documentary about C implants and the de
Community I mean the thing
is Dea the deaf Community had a an an i
and I don't speak for the deaf Community
obviously but I can speak for my own
experience my mother has a c implant she
got one because my mom was like my mom's
like an iconic class and she's like I'm
not going to allow a taboo in De Society
to keep me from experiencing as much of
life as I could possibly experience of
course but in general especially at the
beginning people hated the idea of a c
implant because they do not feel and I
think to some degree I agree with them
that deafness is a disability they feel
that that um that what it is is it's a
it's it's a culture I mean obviously
they can't hear that's a disability but
the true disability comes from the fact
that communication barrier and so to
them they see the klar implant as just
another imperialist now a robotic
mechanism to make them hearing again